he's Ozzie Smith how are you Ozzie hey
we tell you doing huh oh it's better I'm
better for talking to you did you ever
consider playing basketball
Ozzie do you ever have that in you uh
yeah you know Eddie marina I played a
lot of basketball together in high
school and and stuff and we really enjoy
that time but you know when I went to
college I had to do some soul-searching
and I realized that baseball was really
what I love doing more than anything
else so you and Eddie Murray played on
the same high school basketball team oh
yeah we went to Locke high school there
in South Central Los Angeles and he was
drafted we graduated in 73 and he was
drafted by the Baltimore Orioles and I
had to take a different route I had to
go to college I went to a little small
school there in central California
called Cal Poly San Luis Obispo
oh sure I've heard where I didn't get
drafted until 1977 I got drafted by 1976
I got drafted by the Detroit Tigers
which they also drafted Lou Whitaker and
Alan Trammell
they offered me $8,000 $8,500 and I felt
that if they didn't give me 10 grand
they weren't going to take a real good
look at me so I went back and asked for
extra 1,500 which they said was not in
the budget so I went back to school in
hopes of getting drafted again my senior
year which I did by the San Diego Padres
and being a good businessman that I am
rich I signed for $5,000 and a bus
ticket to Walla Walla Washington Wow so
you you're not going to be on Shark Tank
cause you love yourself oh no I'm not
well look everything what happens for a
reason at least that's the philosophy I
grew up with and that that I share today
and look look look what all turned out
for you but when you see the amount of
dollars that's getting thrown around
today it's it's insane you know when you
think about that it's amazing you know
to to watch what has happened but it's
progress and I tell people I was just
born into learning i play my mom I was
born too early what do you what do you
make of the new generation statistics
Ozzie but say if your career had been
measured by things like exit velocity
and things of that nature these new
stats how what do you make of this I
don't know it just becomes
me more bargaining points because when
it at the end of the day either I caught
the ball or I didn't either I was safer
I was out even we wanted we lost and if
you're going out there to do your job
every day
you know you let all of those other
things take care of themselves you know
if there's a guy in it on third base
with less than two dollars my job to get
him in if there's a guy on and no outs
and he's on second base my job is to get
him over and you know I didn't we never
altered from from that that was the way
that we were we were raised that was the
way we were taught the game that hey you
know it's the little things that over
the long haul of 162 games that going to
win games for you and when more
consistently for you so that was that
was the way I was taught that's the way
I played the game and I wouldn't change
that for anything
Ozzie Smith baseball hall-of-famer
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
and the all-star game is just around the
corner as we are as we are heading
towards July who was on the team with
you and 81 that you look back your first
all-star game there first a 15 of them
that was on that and and is something
someone that you marveled today that wow
I played on an all-star team with that
guy or against well you know it was it
was all of the greats at the time you
know Michael Jackson it Gary Carter
you know Tim Raines and all of the
greats that I had a chance to play
against at that particular time and I
always looked at the all-star game I
hear guys now say well I don't really
want to participate in the all-star game
how could you not want to participate in
the all-star game when that's the stage
to be on when you're considered one of
the best or people take their time to
punch your name out on a ballot I
couldn't wait to have the opportunity to
be on that stage to to see whether or
not I was worthy of being there and and
stuff so I always took it I never took
it lightly I always took it as an honor
to to be named to an all-star team and
and I took it with a lot of pride
well I mean who it was there anybody on
the back end of their career in 81 who
you know great from the 50s or 60s or
that that you don't play with or play
against no it's just being there you
know I can remember there was a play
that I had that I made late and you know
I Tommy used to hug all his players and
everything and those sort of sort of was
managing the team on time and I can
remember the guy after I made a short
hop play over the middle there I think
it was Lance Parrish that hit a ball
that bounced over the pitchers head I
showed hopping through it and kept going
to the dugout and Tommy gave me a big
hug and they start calling Tommy my dad
and and stuff so it was it was it was
those type of moment that you remember
the most from all-star games and it was
just a lot of fun and to be around the
guys that you competed against and
growing up I never looked at myself as
an as one of those guys you know so it
was very special for me to have the
opportunity to be on the same field with
both the the greats from the American
League and the greats from the from the
National League what a stage to be Ozzie
Smith Hall of Famer joining me here on
on the Rich Eisen show how did it start
with the standing back flips well you
know when I got drafted and and made it
to the big leagues in 1978 after we got
done working how we had to run a couple
miles and I wasn't very fond of running
so I would got the back of the pack and
I had Gene Tenace I had Rowley fingers I
had Dave Winfield I had Gaylord Perry
older guys who were giving me a hard
time about being the young guy and being
at the back of the pack so to show the
guys that I wasn't tired I did a
roundoff back flip and Gene Tenace had
girls that were involved in gymnastics
at the time and he wanted me to show
them that I can do that at some point in
time during the season which we weren't
able to do so faint appreciation day
which was the last day of the season he
and the PR guy thought it would be a
great idea for me to go out to my
position and do that and in San Diego I
was a little reluctant to do that
because the entertainment was the
chicken nothing we did it and lo and
behold it became my trademark
you were reluctant because you didn't
want to show up the chicken well I
didn't want to show up the chicken and I
didn't want to be labeled as a hot dog
you know because that could be taken the
wrong way and I certainly didn't want to
be looked upon as that but you know they
were they convinced me that that people
wouldn't look at it that way and people
liked it so much they asked me to do it
opening day the following year and
trademark was born our trademark was
born nobody ever came in spikes up slid
hard over that sort of thing with you
ozzie no not really I mean guys always
they always slid hard and I knew that
they were always going to slide our
because that was their job their job was
to come in and break up the double play
so I was always well aware of that when
I look at the rules and things that they
have now I go more then on they're
taking it easy on guys now we always had
the threat of guys coming down and I can
remember some of the guys who were great
takeout artists you know Terry Whitfield
Monty Smith um Bill Madlock Dave Parker
Billy North they all got down there so
quickly you know so you had to be on
your own you're on your toes at all
times and aware of the fact that the
guys were we're coming to take you out
because that was their job bill Madlock
I haven't heard that name in a while he
was he was he could be nasty and now
that'll get you suspended
Razi now they can't rule that right it's
a lot easier these days you know but but
it's it's the changing times it is that
it is that when was it when was the last
time you did a backflip when was that
last 2002 it was not pretty rich what do
you mean it was not pretty I I scraped
my knee I pulled a calf muscle messed up
a pair of pants it was ugly what if we
put you in some sort of apparatus and a
trampoline or you know you'd have to put
me in some type of apparatus to do it
today but even if we gave you some time
to Train anything like that well I don't
know I would need a long time to think
yeah I'm scared now rich okay last
couple of minutes here with Ozzie Smith
baseball hall-of-famer who is the
shortstop you like to watch today that
you say you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna check this guy out because I like
his game
who's that how pretty they're all very
very good and
let me give you a couple here you don't
Lindor and please it was pretty good
Korea and Houston is good but the guy
that I think has been one of the most
underrated shortstops in the game and I
think he's been part of the reason that
his team has turned around because he
gave them stability that they didn't
have up the middle and that Brandon
Crawford in San Francisco I think is one
of the most underrated players who does
it does his job every day you know goes
about it the right way not a lot of
flair and flan flash and all that but
very sound fundamentally and does it the
right way and I enjoy watching him play
how about that so what are you doing
with Kingsford Charcoal right around
July I partnered with kingfish charco to
continue the conversations like we're
having about who people think are the
best of who they thought we had the the
best play of a week the season and so
forth and earlier this season we hosted
a contest that gave the fans a chance to
win a VIP trip to this year's all-star
game and talk about the trip of a
lifetime for passionate fans that have
the opportunity to go down and see all
the stars all over on the stage and now
that that's over we still have a lot of
baseball that's left to be playing and a
lot of grilling to be done and we still
want fans to share their baseball
conversations with us on social media
using the hashtag best of baseball and
to continue these great conversations
that's what makes this game so great
all right on Z hashtag best of baseball
and check you out and Twitter at STL's
for short for st. Louis wizard we'll
check out thanks for joining on Z love
chat all right thank you guys you're
gonna that's Ozzie Smith Hall of Fame
the Rich Eisen shown weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to